(APPLAUSE)
THE SUPER BOWL IS SUNDAY.
IT'S THE BIGGEST ADVERTISING DAY
OF THE YEAR AND BECAUSE EVERYONE
KNOWS SEX SELLS, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #SEXYRESTAURANTS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE
"PANDA SEX-PRESS,"
"BAREBACK STEAK HOUSE..."
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
(LAUGHING)
DON'T ASK FOR THE BLOOMING
ONION.
(CROWD GROANS)
(APPLAUSE)
NO, DON'T EVEN PATRONIZE ME!
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK, GO!
KYLE DUNNIGAN.
>> BLUMPKIN DONUTS.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: THAT'S ONE OF MY
FAVORITE WORDS.
POINTS!
JONAH RAY.
>> JACK-IN-A-BOX.
>> Chris: POINTS!
RIKI LINDHOME?
>> CALIFORNIA (BLEEP) KITCHEN.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I LOVE THAT YOU SAID
IT LIKE TRACY FLICK FROM
ELECTION, YOU HAD THAT
DETERMINATION.
POINTS.
JONAH RAY.
>> FIVE GUYS.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS!
RIKI LINDHOME.
CHIK-FELLATIO.
>> Chris: YES, OF COURSE!
JONAH RAY.
>> DUNKIN' DEEZ NUTS.
(LAUGHING)
>> Chris: YES, KYLE DUNNIGAN.
>> INTERNATIONAL HOUSE OF TITS,
AND IT'S SHORT: I-HOT.
>> Chris: POINTS, YES!
RIKI?
>> BLACK ANUS STEAKHOUSE.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS!
JONAH RAY.
>> BASKIN THROBBINS.
>> Chris: YES!
I NEVER WANT THIS TO END.
KYLE DUNNIGAN.
>> BENN-AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAINS.
>> Chris: YES, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
WELL DONE!
THAT WAS THE END OF A PHENOMENAL
#HASHTAGWARS.